and mr lynch went on to um say that he
was hoping for coordinated action from
other unions
as well um during the summer uh here in
the united kingdom pat mcfadden is uh
with us now hello to mr mcfadden is that
something that labour would support
no it's not we
very much regret that it's come to this
strike it will cause
enormous
inconvenience to the public as you've
been reporting on your program
today we've got this strike today others
scheduled later in the week and perhaps
the bigger threat of ongoing industrial
disputes through the summer
no one wants to see this
we want to see this brought to an end as
quickly as possible with a deal that
allows the railways to work
and the traveling public to get to work
and all the other uses that people make
of the railway system
yeah but my question is would labor
support coordinated action by other
unions to support the rmt and also to
further their cause
no i answered we we don't want to see
that we want to see these things settled
by negotiation we understand why people
are pressing for
pay rises it's only a few months since
the prime minister stood up at the tory
conference and said that he supported a
high-wage economy that we were breaking
with the old model of a low-wage economy
and now we've got inflation
uh touching 10 so we understand why
people are pressing for pay rises but
it's far better
for these things to be resolved in a
proper way
in a negotiation
rather than the
huge inconvenience to the public that's
going to be caused by this dispute today
okay just let me ask you one more time
would labor support coordinated action
by other unions
no we don't want to see
lots of industrial disputes we want
these things to be resolved by
negotiation i hope i've been clear on
that okay
for the third time
okay let me ask you about uh a
shadow uh minister on a picket line this
morning is that something that you would
do
uh it's not something i'll be doing
today what i'll be doing today is using
every opportunity that i can to
urge a negotiated settlement i don't
want to see the government use this
strike as some kind of divisive wedge
issue of the week
i think the public deserves better than
that given the inconvenience
that they're going through today and
also given the prospect of further
industrial action in other sectors
ministers can't stand back and view this
as a political opportunity instead they
have to view it as a responsibility
particularly given the prime minister's
pledge for a high-wage economy that he
made just a few months ago
a shadow minister on the picket line is
it something you support if it's not
something that you would do
no i i don't think that's the way that
this will be resolved i think it will be
resolved by the union the employers and
hopefully the government being involved
in reaching a deal that allows the
railways uh to resume operation and
that's what i want to see as quickly as
possible
do you expect her to be disciplined by
the leader given that apparently uh he
had uh emailed to say that people should
your members should
the shadow cabinet and shadow minister
should not be taking part uh in this
industrial action by supporting people
on the picket line
well that's a matter for the wips and
for kier stammer it's not something i
would be involved in
okay
chatting to both uh both sides of the
dispute today when i say both sides i
mean the government and the union and
and both pretty incalcerant uh neither
uh looks as though they are going to be
getting around the table again anytime
soon in fact uh we heard uh from uh the
uh government in the form of grant chaps
and he was saying um it would actually
make matters worse if he got involved
yeah i heard him say that and
uh i think that maybe what's changed
from the past
uh is the attitude of government overall
to this you know we've had a lot of talk
in recent days about the 1970s and there
are
uh you know echoes of this we're having
to wait a lot longer for things we're
having to wait for passports for driving
licenses for gp appointments uh people
are waiting longer at the airport and so
on now you've got these industrial
disputes it seems like
we've got a government that's losing its
grip
issue by issue that's what's different
to the recent past things that we used
to take for granted are taking so much
longer and the government seems to have
no idea how to fix these problems we're
living in very much a backlog britain
right now and we've got to get back to
having a government with a grip that's
able to sort these things out
yeah to be fair the winter discontent
was a labor government
[Music]
40 years ago it was and we paid a very
big political price
about that and if i could act as an
advisor to the government right now they
might not want my advice
but if they want to learn from that they
might learn that standing back and
watching this unfold and not trying to
get a grip of it
may not end happily for them because
whoever is responsible for this dispute
is certainly not the party that's been
in opposition for the last 12 years
so grant shap said it's not his job to
get involved with the negotiations why
is he wrong
i just don't think that will hold if
we've got a prospect not just of uh
several strikes this week on the
railways but possibly that railway
strike spinning on into
the summer and disputes in other areas
too is he going to appear or
he and fellow ministers going to appear
on your program for weeks on end saying
it's nothing to do with us i think we
need a government again
not just a permanent political campaign
that sees every issue that comes along
as an opportunity to divide people and
sadly
that's been the approach to this dispute
and the approach to so many issues which
are arising week to week right now
how concerned are you that we are
heading towards the summer of discontent
i think it's worrying
if you look at the newspapers this
morning you see
that of course the railways are front
and center of what we're talking about
but they're not the only issue where
there are pay pressures those pay
pressures are understandable given the
inflation figures of course people are
going to
try to campaign
for a decent pay rise
but what we don't want to see is a
summer of discontent
a series of industrial disputes that
will be bad for the public i want to see
these things properly resolved through
collective bargaining through
negotiation
through the mechanisms that are there
that's going to be best for the country
rather than
this dispute today being replicated in
other sectors
but but what else can the government do
you know they can't accordingly even
according to the governor of the bank of
england they cannot put in place uh
inflation busting pay rises uh because
otherwise we will continue to spiral as
far as our inflation issues are
concerned do you have at least some
sympathy for the government
look i understand the position but we've
got a short-term problem and a long-term
problem as usual the short-term problem
is resolving these disputes and helping
people with the cost of living crisis
right now but this didn't happen
overnight the reason that we've got such
pay pressure is because we've had a
decade of stagnating pay and the reason
we've had a decade of stagnating pay is
we've had very poor economic growth in
this country for the last 10 years let
me give you an example if we'd continued
with the kind of economic growth and the
growth in pay that we had in the first
decade of this century when my party
were in power wages would be on average
11 000 pounds a year higher right now
that would be an entirely different set
of circumstances so what we the reason
that pay is under such pressure at the
moment is because of the long economic
record of poor growth that we've seen
under the conservatives so i don't just
want to see a resolution to this dispute
i want to see us get better economic
growth in the future so the country
becomes more prosperous and so do people
at work
yeah but this government had a pandemic
to contend with and we are where we are
um what you you give me the figure of 11
000 pounds a year better off but
nevertheless we are where we are what
can the government do if they start to
bust inflation with pay rises uh public
sector pay rises then it's just going to
continue on and on and on is what the
government says
well as i say they've got to do two
things they've got to do everything they
can to strain every every sinew to get
help to people through this short term
period we hope of the cost of living
crisis but the long term does matter
okay if we don't get better economic
growth in the future than we've had in
the past 10 years then we are going to
be locked in a cycle of people being
unable to pay their bills
upward pressure on taxes it all comes
back to economic growth so this does
matter in the long term and i see no
long-term plan for the kind of
challenges that the country is facing
and that's one of the reasons why the
government lurches from issue to issue
chaos to chaos with no plan other than
asking themselves how can we use this to
divide people how can we use this as a
wedge issue it's really not good enough
so they've got to do things in the short
term to resolve these disputes and help
people with the cost of living crisis
we've got to get better economic growth
in the future
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
so much for taking the time much
appreciated thank you
thank you